William Lutz what is doublespeak
doublespeak is language designed to
evade responsibility make the unpleasant
a clear pleasant the unattractive appear
attractive basically it's language that
pretends to communicate but really
doesn't it is language designed to
mislead while pretending not to
is it done consciously oh yes very
consciously doublespeak is not a slip of
the tongue or a mistaken use of language
it's exactly the opposite is language
used by people who are very intelligent
and very sophisticated in the use of
language and know that you can do an
awful lot with language who's the worst
offender in sheer bulk yes sheer numbers
of examples the government if we count
government from the local level all the
way up to the federal level I had to
stop writing the chapter on government
doublespeak it was going to take over
the whole book but interestingly enough
and this was a revelation in doing the
book about a half a step behind comes
business with a tremendous amount of
doublespeak how long has the government
been using double street I think of
government as the third oldest
profession and probably from the moment
government was instituted doublespeak
came with it I cite examples from the
5th century BC and Greece Julius Caesar
when he pacified Gaul of course Nazi
Germany thrived in doublespeak so it's
been around for quite a while when did
you first get interested in this in 1978
I became head of the Committee on Public
doublespeak
and in 1980 I started editing the
quarterly review of doublespeak and
that's when I became very interested in
it some of because I edited I have all
the examples of doublespeak sent to me
and so I wade through them all what got
you interested in my interest in
rhetoric I did in my PhD I did work in
rhetoric and I was interested in
rhetoric and in 1977 I published a
textbook called the age of communication
which was a little different at the time
I tried to examine the rhetoric of
television radio the mass media
advertising taking a Aristotle's
classical rhetoric and apply it to
modern media
a lot of fun doing that and as a result
of that textbook I was asked to join the
committee and I saw rhetoric and
language coming all together and
doublespeak in an interesting way
universities also have a problem with
doublespeak don't they oh yeah so I I
continually bite the hand that feeds
when I cite Rutgers and I at least every
issue I have an example from Rutgers
University one of my favorite we don't
have a physical education department at
Rutgers we have a Department of Human
Kinetics why well I also point out in my
book that people in physical education
have come up with all of these different
terms because they've gone professional
they now have their own journals so they
have their own academic jargon and as
the Dean at Minnesota who wanted to
change name of his physical education
school said we're not taken seriously
unless we have a name like this we can't
get the grants we can't publish the
articles how long have you been in
Rutgers since 1971 what do you teach I
teach a variety of courses in the
English department but I teach rhetoric
linguistics and some Victorian
literature and I also teach a survey
course that's required of all students
we start with the Iliad and the Odyssey
and work our way up is there any example
in history in ancient history in
literature of doublespeak yes I won
eyesight just as a passing example is
through Sidda T's in the 5th century BC
in the Peloponnesian War during the war
there was a very vicious civil war in
Athens at that time and the acidities
points out that at that time the very
language itself became corrupted to
their own ends acts of cowardice became
acts of great bravery traitorous deed
towards friends became patriotic acts
and he cites the whole list and it's
interesting that through Sidda T cites
this corruption of language is the
ultimate in horror that occurred during
that Civil War do you ever personally
find yourself using doublespeak oh yeah
when I was head of the department I had
to engage in double speak do you have to
write recommendations
have to write personnel evaluation forms
I had the pitch for more money and so
you used the doublespeak of bureaucracy
as anyone else if I were a bureaucrat
who would function within the
bureaucracy using straight language I
wouldn't be taken seriously it's a sort
of ritualistic use of language are you
in this whole world of double street
because you want to get rid of it oh yes
I don't think you'll ever get rid of it
I don't think we can it is inherent in
the function of language to to use
language to as a weapon or as a tool to
manipulate other people however I think
there are two things we can do first of
all we can all become much more aware of
this language we should be aware of it
so that we can at least be defensive and
defend ourselves so that we're not
misled through it but secondly there are
times when we simply cannot tolerate
this language when we talk about
important public issues of national
policy we should not use doublespeak as
a nation we should not use it ourselves
we should not allow the politicians who
are speaking to us to use it language
that way can be terribly corrupting in a
society and can mislead all of us and in
the democracy that depends upon the
active participation of its citizens it
can lead to cynicism and resentment and
withdrawal from the political process is
that does that have anything to do the
reason why they only put 2% of the
American people voted 1988 I have a
hypothesis that I would love to test and
I hope some time to be able to do that I
would love to to be able to track the
pervasiveness of doublespeak as it grew
along with the decline in voting because
the reaction I get to doublespeak from a
lot of readers of the quarterly review
as they write to me is well of course I
know this language I see it all over the
place I see it all the time but you know
what what else can you expect from
politicians they all lie they all use
doublespeak
it is that cynicism which leads to
there's nothing I can do about it so
people withdraw and pull back this book
guys in the bookstores yes it is
it's 1795 yes
how'd you do this book I did the book
and somebody wanted to ask me how long
did
take you to write the book I said it
took me 10 years to research it in six
months to write it I sat down and tried
to make sense out of all the doublespeak
that I've been collecting because there
is a tendency to have a perception that
it is scattered here either in yon the
function of the book is to gather it and
focus it to show you that there is a
pattern and a progression to this
language and I structured the book have
a lot of fun in the beginning and the
humorous uses of doublespeak but leading
to the more important uses of
doublespeak by government the pentagon
and the issues of nuclear war and peace
and how doublespeak corrupts that whole
process a couple little things how did
you choose harpin row actually it there
were two or three publishers and I chose
Harper enroll because of the editor at
Harper & row who then Deusen who was one
of the most respected editors in the
profession and it was someone I thought
would understand the book and would help
me focus it and guide it and that's why
I went with Harper and row did you name
it well yes I did
I had a whole bunch of titles and I was
I was advised not to call it double
speak to come up with some other kind of
descriptive title but I wanted to
because a lot of people aren't sure what
they mean by double speak so I put the
subhead in there from revenue
enhancement to terminal living people
recognized that immediately they they
may not be quite sure what doublespeak
is but boy they know what revenue
enhancement is in terminal living
they've seen enough of that language
around is it selling it's in the fourth
printing what's that mean it means that
they sold out the first printing they
sold out the second printing the sold
out the third printing and they're into
the fourth and the book stores can't
keep it on the shelves so a lot of
bookstores don't have it because it's
backordered they sell them as fast as
they can get them in the stores how big
is it printing well the first printing
was 17,500 the second and third printing
for 6,000 copies each and I think the
third printing was bigger but I'm not
sure how much I haven't found out how
much that is so it's at least another
6,000 have you had any feedback ah the
feedback I've gotten from reviewers
which generally liked the book the only
thing I've been faulted for is my humor
I guess I'm a little too funny at times
for their taste the otherwise the
response from the press has been
interesting
awful lot of reporters Associated Press
did two stories on the book there were
wire press stories in England and you
can't even buy the book in England and
I've done interviews with the BBC and a
friend of mine who lives in Ireland
called me up and said it was all in the
newspapers there and he said you can't
even buy the book here and they they
were all interested in it so the press
the working press has been fascinated by
the book and I've gotten a lot more
reaction from the press and I have from
the traditional book reviewers have you
been on the book tour yes I've done the
books to her and I'm an academic this is
my ninth book but it's my first trade
book I was unprepared for the world of
trade publishing my wife is a novelist
she's done two novels she knows the
world of trade publishing and she has
cautioned me about it what's the word
trade me trade as opposed to academic
you go into the bookstore and and you
can buy the book academic publishing is
done by University Press and is more
restricted and you will find these
generally in the bookstore and it's a
much smaller audience and smaller press
run it's this is mass market this is
writing to the public and so when I did
the book tour I was introduced into the
world of of trade publishing I found it
fascinating when I was in Washington DC
for my tour just ahead of me was justice
judge Bork and just behind me was
William Colby we were all making the
tour pushing our books and you would go
go from radio station the TV station to
press interview and and I find that
fascinating world I met a lot of other
authors I met Steve Hammond a few other
people but we're all pushing the book it
doesn't make any difference who you are
what surprised you most about the book
tour ah
it is tough it's physically demanding
its mentally exhausting and everyone
does it it doesn't matter
Amma Bombeck Steve Allen big names that
you would think name alone would sell
the book they're out there doing exactly
the same tour and I think that that's
important though because I get a sense
of audience when I talk to interviewers
and you talk to a variety of people you
see how your writing is perceived the
writer never really knows what the
audience
CAES in the text so every time I went in
I would be asked something about the
book that I hadn't even thought about or
something that I didn't think was
significant or important or particularly
interesting I just put in there for
whatever reason they thought was the
most fascinating thing and zeroed in on
it what's the most often asked question
the chapter on food and food doublespeak
everyone goes after that one about is it
true that that you can put sugar free on
a product and still have sugar in it
it's probably the one question I've been
asking off most often because people
simply can't believe that the Fanta
happens how can it happen because sugar
free simply means they have an added
table sugar or cane sugar to it they can
add Manos fructose any other syrup
sweeteners and still call it sugar free
so you know when you eat something at
certain freezer sugar hello yes and by
the way I found out in a radio interview
when they had people in the audience
calling in man called it and said do you
mean that there's sugar in there I said
well yes there's sugars in that food so
well I'm a diabetic and my wife make
sure she buys only the sugar free I said
you can't eat those you have to use only
the Dietetic because that's governed by
law sugar free isn't here's a man who is
threatening his health through this this
kind of false labeling it was absolutely
amazing
but things the food chapter has really I
guess we're all interested in food for
some reason I've been asked endless
questions on that chapter is there a
particularly unusual question that you
were asking one of those college shows
usually on the call-in shows people call
in to give me their examples of
doublespeak witches I always like
because I get to write things down but
the most unusual question I think I was
asked was I'm trying to think of how he
put it he wanted to know how many
examples of doublespeak to that effect
if there was an account he want to know
if I had counted it and you know I've
never even thought of that and I have no
idea of how many examples I have because
I all of the examples that I that I
gather I have in a computer database so
I can call them up quickly and
very quickly I have no idea how many I
haven't I do know I have a lot any part
of the country that was more interested
than others Washington DC was far more
interested in it than than any other
parts of the country it was interesting
when Harper & row went to market the
book there was very little interest in
it by West Coast distributors there was
a minimal interest in it I think they
took copies simply because the first
print run was so large they figured you
can't really ignore a book like that but
they weren't in fact I had phone calls
from Los Angeles George Carlin uses a
lot of the doublespeak in his routines
and he always credits me and he called
me up and he said I want your book but I
can't find it I said try ordering it he
couldn't even get it in his book store
and he said he was trying to get the
book store to stock it for me so but
that part of the country wasn't
interested but the Midwest was
interested with the East Coast New York
and Washington DC the book took off
immediately
is there anything to the possibility
that because we here in this town are
the champions of doublespeak we do we
know we're the champions of devil
speaking can't get out of it I think
it's that people in Washington DC did I
mean kind of proud about that well we
really know this stuff cabbies tell me
this when I you know you're here for the
book tour what's your book and I tell
them for I we know that and the cabbies
will start giving me examples I think
people in Washington DC and New York are
extremely sensitive to language they
live in a language environment that is
probably more intense than other
sections of the country and they're more
aware of it so I think the book struck a
responsive chord for that reason I find
that people a couple people that I've
talked to the first thing they did when
they got the book will pick it up and
they'll look there's an index of
doublespeak terms see if their favorite
term is in there that's the first thing
they want to know and then they'll say
why you didn't include and that's the
reaction it's a personal reaction you
seem like you self-consciously pointed
out in the in the early part of this
book that there are no footnotes is that
because you're a neck admission and you
always had flutes and all the other
books
III write footnotes a lot and I think
I wanted to reach a wide audience and I
had a choice either I could even
documenting it by the way putting the
footnotes in the back and endnotes
anybody reading a text that sees all
these little numbers all the way through
it they just don't I think that it
scares them off and and it changes the
whole tone of the work so I wanted to
say all of these examples are real I can
document all of them but I'm not going
to include the documentation here and in
those instances where I've been asked to
document them I've documented them it's
only got 290 pages small book I think
it's long actually for the material it's
pretty dense material and the challenge
in the book was to make it readable I
didn't want it to be just a listing of
terms I wanted to show that there's a
coherence to this first of all and
secondly that this can be fun and
enjoyable to read at the same time that
it's educational I don't see anything
wrong with laughing and learning at the
same time that's the kind of book that I
wanted to write one of the other books
that you've done you have to get your
everyone in general well at the same
time that I probably said I published a
collection of essays on doublespeak by
the National Council of teachers of
English in which I asked a group of
scholars to each contribute an essay on
an aspect of doublespeak
so I edited those and published that
book I edited the revised edition of the
Webster's new world few hours published
by Simon & Schuster I'm probably one of
the few people who has ever read the
dictionary from cover to cover twice and
and I added to Betsy's ARS and then a
variety of textbooks on rhetoric and on
writing and a book on revolution and
revolutionary theory what did you learn
when you read that dictionary from cover
to cover boy did I learn a lot about
words I learned a lot of archaic words a
lot of archaic definitions but you know
the dictionary is fascinating to read
you can pick it up and flip it open and
start reading a good dictionary too many
of the desk dictionaries are so edited
down that there's no life to the
language or life two words if you get a
good dictionary that that gets into the
backgrounds of the words and the words
in context words are fascinating and fun
and language comes a lot
I on the page and in writing the
thesaurus you get into the the shades of
meaning the nuances and and the power of
words and the images that they can they
can create in your mind what are the
best dictionaries well there's the other
bridge is the dictionary you always want
of reference what does that mean on a
bridge Aden bridge means absolutely
everything is in there they have edited
out nothing every definition every
meaning of the word every example which
is why they on a bridge it's about that
thick the good all the dictionaries that
we deal with our abridged which means
that they take out a lot of the
specialized words and and try to boil
down to a core of words that are
everyday usage and then they'll cut back
even the meanings of the words even
though the thesaurus a word like fix
verb fix can have up to 28 different
meanings but you normally don't list all
28 you will maybe pick 14 or 12 common
usage so what's the difference to
addiction area in two stars a dictionary
gives you the meanings of the words all
the all the meanings and a strict
definition for each one but these RS
gives you synonyms for the word so if
you want to look up the adjective busy
you want synonyms for that word words
that say the same thing but not quite
shades of meaning one of the phrases I
gave was in conference have I just had
an experience a couple weeks ago were
somebody so one of these chosen and
criticize me for using a word
incorrectly and I think the word was
parochial I was referring to something
that was you know special for a small
group in the Roku and she said that
you're just not using every word is
prevention so I tried it off to my
dictionary and found out that I was
right and so a yes so how do you hi who
writes these things and I mean who
writes the dictionary in the first place
lexicographers righted the world
dictionary is produced in Cleveland if
you go to Cleveland Ohio you will find
in a building downtown that there's a
floor that Simon & Schuster has for
their dictionary staff there's a group
of people who sit around and they read
they read magazines newspapers and they
look
words and new meanings of words and
these are pulled out and entered into
the computer and that's that's what you
and what company is salmon is used to
hoop what's the name on that dictionary
Webster's new world dictionary
unabridged they're working on another
bridge today on a bridge I'm not sure
when the next date is coming up they
have a huge collection of new meanings
and new words and whenever they pick
those out they have to take the sentence
in which it was used what's called the
citation so that the meaning is
perfectly clear in that sentence for
that shade of meaning one of the things
that I did in my book I learned from
them all of my examples of doublespeak
are not only real but I have the
original context in which the phrase
occurred or I won't use it so I have
file drawers filled with clippings and
memos and letters that have been sent to
me in which the word is used in context
so that I can see that the example of
doublespeak is real it's serious and how
it is used and that's the only way that
I'll accept an example I'll get off this
dictionary in a second but this is
interesting how many people are involved
in producing the Webster's on a bridge
Dix oh gosh there's a lot of people this
is a big undertaking you'll have I met
the senior editorial staff that I met
consisted of 8 people these are the
senior editors and below them will be
all kinds of other editors and and
citation checkers and any number of
people they're talking a lot of people
to do this did expose it sells millions
of copies
well it will sell over you know a period
of the life of the book will will be 20
30 40 years and then periodically
updating it as they go along but it is
labor intensive computers have really
helped they used to keep all these
citations and index cards by the way in
boxes now of course they can keep it in
a computer database and pull things
together the Random House dictionary was
the first dictionary produced by
computer when they brought out the
Random House 2x dictionary that was the
first one Webster's Random House other
name let's see what is Webster's there's
Random House new America American
heritage those are probably the three
best dictionaries oh then there's the
Webster 7
Collegiate Dictionary what's that mean
to seventh position in seven editions
now they're up to the ninth edition or
something it's Webster's whatever number
they use what about overseas Oxford they
have a dictionary well there's the
Oxford English Dictionary which is the
ultimate dictionary in the world that's
just a joy and a delight to read it
traces the entire history of a word from
its first occurrence in English all the
way through giving you the dates the
sight of the source and the citation you
can look up a word and find its entire
history if you go to the OED as it's
called you can look up the word nun and
nunnery and you will understand why when
when Hamlet turns to aphelion says get
thee to a nunnery she runs off the stage
and tears if you go to the OED and look
up the meaning for nunnery at the time
of Hamlet when the play was written you
will find out that a mint brothel ah
doublespeak is your book and you say
attendance fourth printing who do you
want this to change anything this
specific book and have you seen any
evidence that you know besides the
journalists and the Collins shows and
all that kind of stuff if somebody's
taking this book and using it to change
a boy what a great question to ask I
just got a clipping a newspaper clipping
in which there's a letter to the editor
quoting my book to support the argument
that the person is making about
deceptive language so as my mother said
when she sent me this clip and she ran
across and she said somebody bought your
book and read it it seems I would hope
that I will change things by fruit I
produced what I like to think of as a
handbook for survival in the 20th
century in the in the age of the media
so that people will become critical
consumers of language you know we talk
about the consumer movement where you
have to be aware of the product that you
buy when you go and and purchase
something you have to be aware of the
language that's used in our society you
are just a much as much a consumer of
language as you are a consumer of goods
and so you have to be a critical
consumer of language just as you're a
critical
and if you went across language that
defect that's defective take it back
just like you take back the defective
toaster and say I want an exchange on
this one
give me language that works give me
clear language in your acknowledgments
something popped out of the page I would
like to thank the gracious women of the
for Arts Club of Elkhart Indiana who
listened to an early version of chapter
2 and laughed at all the right places
yes more oh that was I had been
interviewed on The Today Show and woman
called me up from Elkhart Indiana and
said that they had this this club and
they would love to have them come and
talk and I and I said I'm really too
busy and but they were so nice I finally
gave in and and went and had an
absolutely wonderful time the four odds
club in Elkhart Indiana by the way is
very impressive the very large group of
women who are dedicated to the Arts they
have their own Arts Center and they work
very hard at supporting the arts and do
a very very good job of it and I was
their luncheon speaker and I was in the
midst of writing this book and I had no
idea of my audience who was reading this
and would be responding to this and
that's very difficult so I took a long
chapter to and I read a chunk of chapter
2 as my talk and I apologized I said I
should probably give you a prepared talk
of a particular kind but I would like to
read this and they did indeed laugh and
then afterwards as part of the the
luncheon there is a reception line where
I each one of them and they each thank
you for coming and the audience was two
or three hundred people by the way but
they were so wonderful and telling me
what they thought of what I had had just
read of this from this manuscript what
they liked about it what they didn't
like about it so I was really gracious
to them here's one chapter two is all
about therapeutic misadventures the
economically non affluent and deep
chilled chickens the doublespeak of
everyday life everyday living excuse me
what is what is a therapeutic
misadventure I will tell you the
incident and then you can figure it out
in 1982 during a cesarean operation the
anesthetist turned the wrong
and killed the mother and child the
hospital called this a therapeutic
misadventure three weeks ago in Los
Angeles according to the Los Angeles
Times in a series of incidents that the
pathologist called incredible stupidity
and incompetence
the surgeons killed the patient it
included slitting the patient's throat
during surgery this was called a
therapeutic misadventure about
economically non affluent
that's what the president of the City
University of New York called the poor
students and attending the City
University they came from economically
non affluent families deep chilled
chickens Frank Perdue filed a complaint
with the Department of Agriculture that
his competitors were selling frozen
chickens as fresh and the Department of
Agriculture investigated and said no
granted the chickens are packed in ice
at a temperature of 28 degrees
Fahrenheit these are not frozen chickens
these are merely deep chilled chickens
and can therefore be sold as fresh I
suggested that we pack the same
Department of Agriculture bureaucrats
and ice when they hit 28 degrees we
might ask them if they're deep chilled
or frozen you point out that there may
be as many as 1 billion people in the
world speaking yes that's the estimate
is 750 to 1 billion we speak English as
a first or second language why English
it's become well you know it's simply
from both the British Empire and then we
replace the the British as the dominant
economic and political force in the
world and it's natural in history that
that nation which has the greatest
political and economic influence that
language is adopted by all people in the
world Rome had the same function latin
function the same way and so if you saw
the story of English that McNeil did
Robert McNeel did he has the great
episode where he goes to the shipyard in
Singapore and you have a shipbuilding
yard in Singapore where the people
ordering the ships are from Japan the
Japanese
the workers are Singapore natives the
financing is coming from Hong Kong and
somebody else is from the United States
I have an interest in it they all speak
English everyone it's the one language
that they can all share so they don't
have to worry about other languages so
it's become the what's called by
linguist the lingua franca the language
of trade and commerce in the world I've
been trying to total that we had 200 2
million Americans but the 8 million
Brits 17 million Australians 26 million
Canadians do all the Indians in India
speaking a great number of Indians speak
English great number of people in China
Japan you can go to particularly the Far
East and the Near East and find a lot of
people go to Greece one of the
television channels in Greece is all
English its bits broadcast in English
what about the Soviet Union a large
number two in the Soviet Union when I
taught in China for a while and my
students were all they not only spoke
English they were learning to to write
proficiently in English that they would
have a mastery of the written language
was extremely difficult when you learn a
foreign language and for them becoming
very proficient in English was important
for their economic success one of my
students had as his goal to be a
high-level government translator for
example at the very least they could be
tourist guides and have other functions
but being proficient and English wasn't
their only language by the way they had
to know at least two most of my students
were proficient in English and Russian
but for them English was extremely
important and many of them wanted to be
able to study in England or America or a
similar country and proficiency in
English would allow them to do that
do you ever did you ever study another
language oh yes my minors as an
undergraduate were Latin in Greek and
then I also learned some German as a
reading language from a document it is
English easy or difficult as a linguist
no language is any easier or more
difficult than any other language the
linguist
tell you as a practical matter in
pronunciation after you reach a certain
age of maturity you will never be able
to speak a language like a native
speaker because your your your physical
properties of producing speech will will
evolve in such a way that you can't
produce certain sounds as accurately as
a native speaker it's simply a
physiological fact of life but you can
still learn that language what you
really learn when you learn a language
and this is why you should learn a
foreign language you're not a whole
different way of looking at the world
it's tied in with doublespeak language
is a way of perceiving reality it's the
only way we have of looking out there
seeing something and turning to another
person and saying this is what I see now
we can both look up there and you can
say I see a pre-dawn vertical insertion
and I can say gee I see an invasion but
it's through language that we talk about
this reality and we give some kind of
means of expressing that reality when
you learn a foreign language you will
learn a slightly different way of
looking at the world and interpreting
that world Chinese is fascinating
because Chinese it's so different from
English the Chinese don't have pronouns
they don't have gender in their pronouns
it is impossible in Chinese to say well
my son he is going yeah they just don't
have that they don't have is going what
we call the present progressive tense it
does not exist in Chinese the the verb
tense becomes different number becomes
different English is we have singular
and plural and we never even think of
that
plural is defined as two or more in many
languages plural is three or more there
singer
single dual meaning just two and then
plural which is three or more a
different way of seeing things and
dealing with things which is why it's
always interesting to learn another
language although I do think at times a
double speak is in a different language
but probably doesn't qualify as a
foreign language at the beginning again
at the preface you quote George Orwell
and the reason I mention is
because you Appendix C you give the list
of recipients of the George Orwell award
for distinguished contributions to
honesty and clarity in public language
that Messiah George Orwell from politics
and English language 1946 most people
who bother with the matter at all would
admit that the English language is in a
bad way
Orwell's throughout this entire book why
did you pick him well
Orwell in in in these two works his
essay politic is in the English language
and then really giving full full-blown
thought to that essay in his novel 1984
addressed the importance of language in
society and the control and manipulation
of language to control and direct
society I think the most important point
in 1984 is that power grows not out of
the barrel of a gun power grows not out
of the thought police and ruled by
terror it grows out of the power of
language in that novel the revolutionary
act committed by Winston Smith right at
the beginning of that novel is to keep a
diary in keeping a diary any person who
keeps a diary uses language to
communicate with the self you're talking
to yourself and you're thinking through
words about the world around you and
about how you feel that's why diary is
such a revolutionary act in 1984 because
you are reasserting personal control
over language then at the end of the
novel to parallel that scene when
Winston Smith has been found out and
O'Brien his torturer and guide says to
him what is reality reality is not
external reality exists not in the mind
of the individual which soon perishes
but in the mind of the party which is
collective and immortal what the party
says is reality is real and how else can
the party do that except by language
party has taken control of language and
has taken and away from the individual
that's the power because those in power
who control language control the way we
see the world
let's talk about political parties for a
second let me name three for you and
tell me which one is the worst abuser of
doublespeak the communist party the
Democratic Party or the Republican Party
in history I would say I'd give them all
three they're right in there by the
nature of politics I would say that the
Communist Party would be leading the
other two simply because under the time
of Stalin and others language was used
to justify you know mass murder murder
of millions of people exactly the same
as the Nazis did use use a language to
justify murder but as we see any any
politician in power start using
doublespeak the Democrats did I love
Jimmy Carter's comment on the failed
raid to free the hostages in a ring and
he called it an incomplete success he
did that without even thinking about it
he was just automatically using that
kind of language but we had used
language in Vietnam to justify our
actions in Vietnam the Republican Party
once that obtaining power has used
doublespeak to justify and explain and
violence their critics but I don't see
that it's being different from any other
politician what Orwell says in politics
and English language is it is clear that
the corruption of language has
ultimately has political and economic
causes who are your favorite people in
the world the abuse language over the
years that you you think use less
doublespeak than a lot of the others
that are in this book I'm not sure about
less doublespeak I think I think more of
people who were aware of the power of
language and how to use it and use it
effectively or maybe I should ask you
who are the straight shooters who are
the people that say really get to a
straight-in hit you between the eyes boy
that's a tough question because the
closest I could come would be right now
Colin Powell for his his his explanation
of the the war my term in in Panama for
there have been a few
politicians who have been quite blunt of
the Senator Moynihan can when he chooses
to be you can also use doubles week but
he can be pretty blunt when he wants to
be and pretty forceful there are a few
people in Congress and the House of
Representatives who when they choose can
be quite blunt what I find interesting
about that use of language those are
people who are very conscious of when it
is the ritualistic doublespeak that
they're going to use and when they think
they can achieve more by using blunt
language so they can turn it on and turn
it off John Kennedy understood the power
of rhetoric this isn't to say he didn't
use double speak which he did but he
understood that that language had the
power to move us and to inspire us and
to set a public agenda and define
ourselves as a nation and we haven't
seen such language in quite a while
Harry Truman was probably the bluntest
Speaker we ever had as a president for
for not caring about the consequences he
would just say and I think we have
looked back on him now and said boy you
know he really was pretty
straightforward
I have a rule about presidents and
presidential speeches I do not watch
them when they are given I read the text
of the speech first then I watch the
speech so that I am not influenced by
all of the visual trappings that go with
the speech and if you look at the words
in the page you'll get a quite different
message
quite often than the message you'll get
from the visual image I did that with
Oliver North's testimony which comes
across quite different in the printed
page Harry Truman's comments now seem
blunter than ever when read on the
printed page Richard Nixon doesn't seem
quite as flat on the printed page as he
was in life because I think his persona
overshadowed his words and at times his
language isn't as duplicitous that some
people thought it was in some instances
although he was capable as we saw there
in Watergate of of using a lot of
doublespeak
so there's is always a mixture of
language because
anyone who reaches any position of power
must either instinctively
or knowingly know how to use doublespeak
and know how to use it at a certain time
and when to turn it on and off and to
what degree you can simply track that in
anyone's in the rise to politics I'm
trying to think of the great Spencer
Tracy movie
it's a classic film where he's running
for president he's the ordinary man who
gets caught up in the presidential race
and he becomes a national hero and one
of the things they do in the movie is
show that as he moves closer to getting
the nomination he starts using more and
more of what we would call double speak
until finally there comes the scene at
the end of the movie when he gets so
disgusted with what he has become that
he quits the race and will even though
he is by this point become a shoo-in for
the nomination if not the election he
just clicks it but the movie has traced
the compromises that he makes through
language in order to achieve it and I
think that the American public believes
that that in order to get that far you
have to sell off so much that there's
not much left at the other end and that
is reflected in the language that you
use when you write where do you write I
have a fortunate to have my own little
study I have one I'm on one side of the
hall my wife is on the other side doing
her next novel and I have a computer and
sit in and write trying to do as much as
I can I have a rule about writing which
I discovered when I wrote my
dissertation that you never never write
a book you write three pages or you
write five pages otherwise I put off
writing my dissertation for a year
because I couldn't think of writing this
whole thing and then I discovered that
you don't write a book you write three
pages and I had put off doing this book
for quite a while and my wife said
you've got to do the book I said yes I'm
going to live just as soon as I and of
course I did every other thing I could
possibly think of before that
and then I realized one day that she was
right I had to start writing but I was
thinking of writing a book every time I
start a book I go through this so one
day I sit down and I say I'm going to
write five pages that's all and when I'm
done with five pages I'll reward myself
so I do the five pages over the next
time I'll do ten pages or or whatever
number of pages but I set a number of
pages and after a period of time you
have a manuscript do you write a lot at
one time it depends there have been when
I was writing that book I I came
downstairs and said gee I just did 28
pages which is a phenomenal amount of
writing but I hit a section where it
just really flowed and I always begin a
writing session by sitting down and
rewriting what I wrote the previous day
and that's the first thing and it does
two things first of all I make sure
writing a little bit better because
rewriting is the essential part of
writing and the second thing is gets you
flowing again get you back into the
mainstream
Truman Capote once gave the best piece
of advice for writers ever given he said
never
pump the well dry always leave a bucket
there so I knew would never stop writing
when I ran out of ideas
I always stopped when I had something
more to write about and I would write a
note to myself this is what I'm going to
do next and then I stopped the worst
feeling in the world is to have written
yourself dry and then have to come back
the next day knowing that you're dry and
not knowing where you're going to pick
up at this point do you write at home
yes all the times he has it and where is
home it's in a little town called Haddon
Township New Jersey which is right
outside of Philadelphia there a certain
environment the late evening early
morning darkroom all those things that
make it easier for you there is an
environment that's true I once wrote an
essay on this by the way I was asked to
contribute to a book called how I write
and they asked a group of writers to
describe it and in writing about how I
read first time ever thought about it I
realized that there is a ritual that I
engage in in writing and I think every
writer does you have to have a certain
environment I'd like my office and it
has to be and it has to be clean when it
gets too messy I can't write so I'll
spend a day cleaning it up and then
generally I have to start
in the morning or in the ladies one or
the other the middle of the day seems to
be a bad time for me I'll waste a lot of
time in the middle of the day but I can
write late at night or I can write early
in the morning get up and get started
my wife writes very late at night I mean
she's person who says it's two o'clock
it's time to start writing and she can
ride from 2 a.m. to 5 a.m. it's
absolutely amazing how did you two good
together she when she published she had
been a graduate student in the English
department when I was chairman and after
she published her first novel she'd
given me a copy and you know was a
former graduate would gone on to success
and quite proud and so I asked her out
to dinner and a few years later we were
married is it two writers together does
it work she says it doesn't and she said
why did I ever marry a writer I do I
know I should have never married a
writer because she's a novelist and she
creates you know in the creative process
of writing a novel is quite different
from writing nonfiction I've learned an
awful lot about writing I have learned
an awful lot about literature from her
from watching her right and watching the
creative process at work and when she
she goes to writing conferences and
sometimes I go with her and Chief and
there are other writers novelists
they're talking and they all talk the
same way to watch a novelist write a
novel is is tremendously impressive I
don't think I have ever appreciated as
much the the creative act is that to
create a world to create people that are
real in a novel and these people as she
explains to me and to her students in
her creative writing classes what you
see in the novel is about 1/10 of what
the novelist knows about these people in
this world she could tell you absolutely
everything there is to know about these
characters where they went to school
what their favorite foods are that may
never be in the novel but she has to
know these people that well in order to
to write about them in a novel
and a novelist knows that and so a lot
of her writing will be she has a couch
in her office and she'll just be lying
in the couch 2-3 hours because it's just
if there's a gestation period going on
of these people coming to life and then
she'll write for a while and then she'll
go back to thinking and to watch this
process
boy that's a piece of cake for me to
write I mean this is this is nothing and
I wouldn't want to be a novelist for
anything
there's too much pain and suffering and
just damned hard work and writing a
novel in the liner notes it says quote
bill lutz
is the 1990 george orwell Larry King
which Larry King is that that's the
Larry King Larry King
exactly I was in a show twice and we had
a lot of fun in doing the book and when
I when the book came out I had sent in
my a copy and he was kind enough to give
me that blurb but the first time I was
on his show we spent two hours going
through doublespeak and with people
calling in and that and he really
enjoyed it
the reason I asked is that I want you to
go back to the George Orwell sign
because we won't talk a little bit about
the awards and the time we have
remaining who was George Orwell George
Orwell was a British SAS reviewer critic
novelist who published the now classic
novel 1984 but in 1947 he published
politics in English language an essay
which by the way is the most reprinted
essay in the English language it's just
it's just endlessly reprinted in which
he warned about the corruption of
thought through language the examples he
used all came from Stalinist Russia and
Nazi Germany he had during the Second
World War
served in the British Ministry of
propaganda or information and was
introduced to the inside of the
propaganda process and he wrote 1984 as
a novel of the future in which given the
growth of the power of communications
and the sophisticated use of language
totalitarian governments would base
their power upon the control of minds
through language and he really believed
when did he die he died in nineteen
48 of lung disease you think he would
have if people lived he'd have been
surprised about two things one the
popularity of 1984 has a novel and two
what actually happened in those two
Tollett Aryan governments in 1989 he or
both of those first of all then there's
a whole discussion over why this novel
became so popular it was originally
titled by the way the last man in Europe
and it got the title 1984 by flipping
the last two digits of 48 oh by the way
he died in 49 because he died right
after the novel came out novel did only
modestly well after he died however it
got tremendously popular he also
published Animal Farm that classic which
was soundly denounced by the by the
Communist Party and also got him a lot
of press but it wasn't until after his
death that the novel became as popular
as it was in 1984
that novel sold 50,000 copies a week in
the United States in 1984 in 1984 in the
year of 1984 did the fact the novel
exists existed or exists have any impact
on making sure that it really didn't
happen well during 1984 there are of
course a flurry of conferences and
discussions about you know has the world
of 1984 come to pass and of course there
were people who said no look at really
haven't and in the other hand people
said oh yes it has that's a judgment
call I think that in some ways it's far
worse than the world that Orwell
envisioned on the other hand is not as
bad as he envisioned the events in
Eastern Europe show us that it is
becoming almost impossible to control
the information environment as tightly
as Orwell envisioned it the only country
I can think of that can do that now is
North Korea they're the only one that is
completely dramatically sealed from the
rest of the world Romania is trying to
be hermetically sealed and I don't know
how successful they will be but as the
Chinese government found out the
existence of telephones and fax machines
and personal computers simply makes it
impossible to to control language and
therefore ideas in the way that Orwell
in 1984 but I think that what
governments have done is they've just
gone a step beyond that they will let
the information flow they will just try
and control the way that the content of
that flow of information now that George
Orwell word for distinguished
contribution to honesty and clarity in
public language
Donald Bartlett or Barlet and James
Steele reporters from the Philadelphia
Inquirer and 88 yes I won 88 it was
Edward Herrmann professor of Finance at
the that was 88 that was a night they
did a series of articles in the
Philadelphia Inquirer on the tax reform
bill showing that through false
deceptive language that was inserted
into the bill billions of dollars in
special tax breaks were given away to
individuals and companies and
corporations and it was all done through
deceptive language that no one knew
understood the language it was written
in such a way that applied only to one
individual great example one business
was defined as a family farm in that
bill thereby giving them the special tax
breaks for farmers that business employs
twenty five thousand people and has a
growth income of over 1.5 billion
dollars a year the tax bill called him a
family farm 87 was noam chomsky for on
power and ideology 86 was neil postman
amusing ourselves to death 85 was
turbine murder guard and Kim Schroeder
yeah the two danish professors and one
more 84 was Ted Koppel moderator of
ABC's television program Nightline in
general who gives the George Orwell
award and what's usually the reason well
the Committee on Public doublespeak of
the National Council of teachers of
English we take nominations from from
anybody who wants to give us nominations
we vote we have 35 members on the
committee they're all teachers of
English we have one statistician and one
philosopher on the committee and we vote
they what we look for is someone who has
contributed to clarity and language of
public discourse Nightline I think is a
good example Ted Koppel I think is
famous for saying wait a minute here can
we back up and explain that one for a
minute I mean he's very good at doing
that and we think that that contributes
to to clarity and discourse we gave it
too
to Bartlet and steel because of you know
revealing that that intricacies of that
tax law were needlessly done and that
the language was deliberately opaque to
give special tax breaks to a lot of
people in corporations that tens of
billions of dollars worth we think that
that's important that people know about
that that this language is being used to
take money out of their pockets
because somebody's going to have to make
up for that missing tax revenue so we're
looking for people who contribute to
honesty and language clarity and
language of that way
okay the recipients of the doublespeak
award same group give up yes the same
group we go to each year and from the
nominations that we receive and we try
to give the award to as a symbolic award
to an American public figure who has
used doublespeak that had consequences
of some kind on public policy or a
public issue in 1989 we gave it to Exxon
corporation for calling the 35 miles of
shoreline in Alaska environmentally
clean and reporters pointed out that
there was still oil all over the place
and Exxon spokesman said well clean
doesn't mean that every oil stain is off
every Rock
it means the natural inhabitants can
live there may go quickly through the
list through the 80s 80 was Ronald
Reagan 81 was alexander haig 82 is
Republican National Committee 83 Ronald
Reagan 84th department of state 85 the
CIA 86 NASA 87 Lieutenant Colonel Oliver
North and 88 defense secretary Frank
Carlucci Admiral William Crown William
and Rear Admiral William Fogarty a
political question to you if someone
read that list they would think possibly
that this is a one-sided award to only
one side of political spectrum well for
this reason the Republican Party has
been in power for eight years and so you
know when Jimmy Carter was in he got it
so you know we these are the people who
have the power to affect public policy
through their language as I point out
Democrats don't get quoted too much
these days they're not in power if they
get in power they'll be right in there
in the list with everybody else I don't
fit I mean we cited Dukakis during his
campaign for his doublespeak which he
used and if he had been elected
president he'd be in the running along
with everyone else either Republican or
Democratic party better than the other
when it comes to go
now they both uses it it seems to go
with the territory our point is that as
Orwell said its political language and
political language tend to in the
twentieth century to be this kind of
misleading and deceptive language
whether it's Johnson by the way so the
legacy from from the Johnson
administration was the language of
Vietnam and the language of the poverty
program which stopped calling people
pouring started calling them
disadvantaged and stopped talking about
slums and ghettos but the inner city I
mean that's a heritage of doublespeak
from the Johnson administration they go
back to when we start his conversation I
ask you I think in the beginning is this
done on purpose and with calculation and
you said yes yes in fact I excited a
couple incidents incidents in the book
reckoned document it was done one is
revenue enhancement they had a meeting
in the Office of Management and Budget
they said we need a phrase to replace
tax increase they came up with revenue
enhancement when Lawrence Kudlow the
economist was asked why they did that
he said because there's no better way to
sell economic policy than the
euphemistic route he was quite proud of
the fact that they came up with that
phrase and Peacekeeper as the name for
the MX missile again robert mcfarlane
chaired the committee meeting in which
he facetiously suggested that they
couldn't name it
Widowmaker could they so instead they
came up with peace maker but later
President Reagan misread his his cue
cards and said peacekeeper and since it
was a televised speech
it became the Peacekeeper and it was a
name that was deliberately designed to
make a nuclear missile sound nice does
it work
yes of course it were most people don't
hear it they will hear some of it but
not all of it one of my favorite
examples in this past year is the
Resource Development Park that they were
going to establish in Kansas City until
the good folks in the neighborhood where
they were going to put the park asked
what is the Resource Development Park do
you know where the resource development
Park is in Kansas City it's a dump they
were going to put a dump in their
neighborhood until somebody asked what
it meant they deliberately invented that
phrase to try and slip a dump into the
neighborhood without anyone noticing
this until it was too late
we had just have a short time left and
the number of things that are
maybe interested in I've got here in my
hand the quarterly review of doublespeak
is there an organization that you can
join if you want to get into this you
don't have to join you can just
subscribe to that in fact most of the
subscribers are civilian public and not
even English teachers it's eight dollars
a year it's subsidized by the National
Council of teachers of English so that's
why the cost is so low where do you get
you can simply write to the quarterly
review of doublespeak in Urbana Illinois
I've got the 1111 Kenyan Road or vana
Illinois yes six one 801 National
Council of teachers of English and eight
dollars and you're subscribing it in
dear subscribers and what will you get
out of this ah I edit it you will get
all the latest examples of doublespeak
to that that are sent to me which I've
put in their articles on doublespeak
book reviews on books of interest
cartoons short pieces on what's the
latest in advertising doublespeak and I
try to make it fun and funny and
interesting and entertaining at the same
time you also learn things like how to
read public opinion polls so that you're
not misled by the results one last
question your favorite double speak word
or phrase the Department of Defense
which until 1947 was the Department of
War the book is called double speak and
it's written by William Lutz published
by Harper and row in your bookstores
thank you for joining us thank you